good evening
my fellow americans it's been
343 days since the virus
that has ravaged our nation tragically
claimed its first life
on february the 6th in 2020 patricia
dowd
took her last breath at home under the
california sun
in santa clara she was 57 years old
a beloved wife mother daughter
sister she never knew she had the virus
at the time when most folks never heard
about
the virus but just like that
she was gone and almost exactly one year
later
nearly four hundred thousand four
hundred thousand of our fellow americans
have met the same
cruel fate countless families
and friends left behind with unrelenting
grief and guilt
anger and frustration and the emptiness
felt by the loss of life is compounded
by the loss of our way of life
during this pandemic millions of
americans
through no fault of their own have lost
the dignity and respect
that comes with a job and a paycheck
millions of americans never thought
they'd be out of work
many of them never even can vision the
idea
are facing eviction waiting for hours in
their cars
to feed their families as they drive up
to a food bank
millions have kept their jobs
but have seen their hours and paychecks
reduced barely hanging on as well
that's happening today in the united
states of america
just was in the midst of a dark winter
of this pandemic
as cases hospitalizations and deaths
spike at record levels there is
real pain overwhelming
the real economy
one where people rely on paychecks
not their investments to pay for their
bills
and their meals and their children's
needs
you won't see this pain if you score if
your scorecard is how things are going
on wall street
but you will see it fairly clearly if
you examine
what the twin crises of a pandemic and
this
sinking economy have laid bare
the growing divide between those few
people at the very top
who are doing quite well in this economy
and the rest of america
just since this pandemic began
the wealth of the top 1 percent of the
nation has grown roughly
1.5 trillion
since the end of last year four times
the amount for the entire bottom
50 of american wage earners
some 18 million americans are still
relying on unemployment insurance
some 400 000 small businesses have
permanently closed their doors and it's
not hard to see
that we're in the middle of the once in
several generations economic crisis
with a once in several generations
public health crisis
the crisis of deep human suffering is in
plain sight
and there's no time to waste we have to
act and we have to act
now this is what economists are telling
us more importantly
it's what the values we hold dear in our
hearts as americans are telling us
a growing chorus of top economists agree
that the moment of crisis in this moment
of crisis
with interest rates at historic lows we
cannot afford
inaction it's not just that smart
fiscal investments including deficit
spending are more urgent than ever
is that the return on these investments
in jobs
racial equity will prevent long-term
economic damage and the benefits will
far out surpass far surpass the cost
a growing number of top economists have
shown even our debt situation
will be more stable not less stable
if we seize this moment with vision and
purpose
and so tonight i'd like to talk to you
about our way forward
a two-step plan of rescue and recovery
a two-step plan to build a bridge to the
other side of the crisis we face
to a better stronger more secure america
tonight i'll lay out my first step
the american rescue plan that will
tackle the pandemic and get direct
financial assistance and relief
to americans who need it the most
next month my first appearance
before a joint session of congress i
will lay out my bill back better
recovery plan
it'll make historic investments in
infrastructure that build back better
plan
infrastructure manufacturing innovation
research and development
and clean energy investments in a
caregiving economy and skills and
training needed
by our workers to be able to compete and
win in the global economy
of the coming years moody's
an independent wall street firm said my
approach will create
more than 18 million good paying jobs
our rescue and recovery plan is a path
forward
with both seriousness of purpose
and a clear plan with transparency and
accountability
with a call for unity that is equally
necessary
and unity is not some pie in the sky
dream
it's a practical step to getting the
things we have to get done as a country
get done together as i said when it
passed in december
the bipartisan kova 19 relief package
was a very important
first step i'm grateful for the
democrats republicans and independent
members of congress
who came together to get it done but i
said at the time
it's just a down payment we need more
action
more bipartisanship and we need to move
quickly we need to move fast
our rescue plan starts aggressively in
order to speed up our national covet 19
response
the vaccines offer so much hope we're
grateful to the scientists and
researchers
and everyone who participated in the
clinical trials
we're also grateful for the rigorous
review and testing
that has led to millions of people
around the world already being
vaccinated safely
but the vaccine rollout in the united
states has been a dismal failure thus
far
tomorrow i will lay out our vaccination
plan
to correct course and meet our goal of
100 million
shots at the end of my first 100 days as
president
this will be one of the most challenging
operational efforts we have ever
undertaken as a nation
we'll have to move heaven and earth to
get more people vaccinated to create
more places for them to get vaccinated
to mobilize more medical teams to get
shots in people's arms to increase
vaccine supply
and to get it out the door as fast as
possible
we'll also do everything we can to keep
our educators and students safe
to safely reopen a majority of our k-8
schools by the end of the first 100 days
we can do this if we give the school
districts
the schools themselves the communities
the states the clear guidance they need
as well as the resources they need
that they can't afford right now because
of the economic
dilemma they're in that means more
testing and transportation
additional cleaning and sanitizing
services in those schools
protective equipment and ventilation
systems in those schools
we need to make sure that workers who
have covet 19
symptoms are quarantined and those who
need to take care of their family
members with covet 19 symptoms
should be able to stay home from work
and still get paid
this will reduce the spread of the virus
and make sure workers get the support
they need to maintain their families
but but they need about we need about
400 billion in funding from congress
to make all of what i just said happen
it's a great deal but i'm convinced we
are ready to get this
done the very health of our nation is at
stake
our rescue plan also includes immediate
relief to americans hardest hit
and most in need we will finish the job
of getting a total of two thousand
dollars
in cash relief to people who need it the
most
the six hundred dollars is simply not
enough
you just have to choose between paying
rent
and putting food on the table even for
those who've kept their jobs
these checks are really important you
see if you're an american worker
making forty thousand dollars a year
with less than four hundred dollars in
savings
maybe you've lost hours or maybe you're
doing fewer shifts
driving the truck or caring for the kids
or the elderly
you're out there putting your life on
the line to work during this pandemic
and worried every week that you get sick
lose your job or worse two thousand
dollars is going to go a long way
to ease that pain we'll also provide
more peace of mind for struggling
families by extending
unemployment insurance beyond the end of
march for millions of workers
that means that 18 million americans
currently rely on unemployment benefits
while they look for work can count on
these checks continuing to be there
plus it will be a 400 per week
supplement
so people can make ends meet
this gets money quickly into the pockets
of millions of americans
who will spend it immediately on food
and rent
and other basic needs as the economists
tell us that helps the whole economy
grow
we'll also tackle the growing hunger
crisis in america
as i speak and the vice president-elect
has spoken to this many times
one in seven households in america more
than one in five black and latino
households in america
report they don't have enough food to
eat
this includes 30 million adults and as
many as 12 million children
it's wrong it's tragic it's unnecessary
it's unacceptable so we're going to
extend
emergency nutritional assistance for 30
43 million children and their families
enroll in the snap program
through the rest of this year we'll help
hard his restaurants prepare
meals for the hungry provide food for
the families who need it
we will invest three billion dollars in
making sure
mothers and their young children have
the nutrition they need
this will not only meet our moral
obligation we have to one another
but also spur economic growth get
restaurants and workers back on the job
and as we work to keep people from going
hungry
we'll also work to keep a roof over
their heads
to stem the growing housing crisis and
evictions that are looming
approximately 14 million americans have
fallen behind on rent
many at risk of eviction if we don't act
now there'll be a wave of evictions and
foreclosures in the coming months
as the pandemic rages on
this would overwhelm emergency shelters
increase
cover 19 infections as people have
nowhere to go and can't socially
distance
next week we'll take action to extend
nationwide restrictions on evictions and
this will provide this will provide more
than 25 million americans
greater stability instead of living on
the edge every single month
and i'm asking congress to do its part
by funding rental assistance
for 14 million hard hit families and
tenants
it will also be a bridged economic cover
recovery for
countless mom-and-pop landlords
these crises are straining the budgets
of states and cities and tribal
communities
that are forced to consider layoff and
service restrictions of the most needed
workers
it means that people putting their lives
at risk
are the very people now at risk of
losing their jobs
police officers firefighters
all first responders nurses educators
you know
over the last year alone over 600
000 educators have been lost
have lost their jobs in our cities and
towns
our rescue plan will provide emergency
funding to keep these essential workers
on the job
and maintain essential services we'll
ensure that vaccines are administered
and schools can reopen
vice president-elect harris and i have
been speaking with county officials
mayors governors of both parties on a
regular basis
we're ready to work with them help them
get the relief they need
our rescue plan will also help small
businesses
that are the engines of our economic
growth
our economy at whole as a whole the glue
that holds communities together as well
but they're hurting badly and you
realize they account for nearly
half of the entire total u.s workforce
our rescue plan will provide flexible
grants to help those hardest hit
small businesses survive the pandemic
and the low-cost capital that will help
entrepreneurs of all backgrounds create
and maintain jobs plus provide
the essential goods and services that
communities depend upon
last week i laid out how we'll make sure
that our
emergency small business relief is
distributed swiftly and equitably
unlike the first time around we're going
to focus on small businesses on main
street
we'll focus on minority-owned small
businesses women-owned small businesses
and finally having
equal access to the resources they need
to reopen
and to rebuild
and we will be responsible with
taxpayers dollars ensuring
accountability
that reduces waste and fraud and abuse
like we did in the recovery act
that i administered in our
administration direct cash payments
extended unemployment insurance rent
relief food assistance
keeping essential front-line workers on
the job
aid to small businesses these are the
key elements to the american rescue plan
that would lift 12 million americans out
of poverty
and cut child poverty in half that's
5 million children lifted out of poverty
if we move
our plan will reduce poverty in the
black community
by 1 30 reduced poverty in the hispanic
community by almost
40 percent and includes much more
like an increase in the minimum wage to
at least
15 an hour people tell me that's going
to be hard to pass florida just passed
it as divided as that state is
they just passed it the rest of the
country is ready to move as well
it should be a national minimum wage of
15 an hour
no one working 40 hours a week should
live
below the poverty line that's what it
means if you work
for less than 15 an hour and work 40
hours a week you're living in poverty
it includes access to affordable child
care that will come able parents
particularly women to get back to work
i look forward to working with members
of congress both parties
to move quickly to get of the american
rescue plan to the american people
then we can move with equal urgency and
bipartisanship to my build back better
recovery plan
that i will call for next month to
generate
even more economic growth american
manufacturing
was the arsenal democracy in world war
ii
it will be so again imagine a future
made in america all made in america
and all by americans
we'll use taxpayers dollars to rebuild
america
we'll buy american products supporting
millions of american manufacturing jobs
enhancing our competitive strength in an
increasingly
competitive world imagine historic
investments in research and development
to sharpen america's innovative edge in
markets where global leadership is up
for grabs
markets like the battery technology
artificial intelligence
biotechnology clean energy
imagine confronting the climate crisis
with american jobs
and ingenuity leading the world
it's time to stop talking about
infrastructure
and to finally start building an
infrastructure
so we can be more competitive millions
of good paying jobs
to put americans to work rebuilding our
roads our bridges our ports
to make them more climate resilient to
make them faster cheaper cleaner
to transport american-made goods across
our country and around the world
that's how we compete
and imagine millions of jobs in a
caregiving economy
to ease the financial burden
of caring for young children and aged
loved ones
let's make sure our caregivers mostly
women women of color immigrants
have the same pay and dignity that they
deserve
so we can do these bold practical things
now
now
you know i know what i just described
does not come cheaply
but failure to do so will cost us dearly
the consensus among leading economists
is we simply can't
not afford not to do what i'm proposing
independent respected institutions from
around the world from the federal
reserve
to the international monetary fund have
underscored the urgency
even wall street firms have reinforced
the logic
if we invest now boldly smartly
and with unwavering focus on american
workers and families
we will strengthen our economy reduce
inequity
and put our nation's long-term finances
on the most sustainable course
and where we're making permanent
investments recurring investments
as i said in the campaign trail we will
pay for that by making sure that
everyone pays their fair share
not punishing anybody we can do without
punishing a single person by closing tax
loopholes for companies that ship jobs
overseas
or they'll allow american companies 90
of them the top fortune 500 to pay
zero in federal income taxes asking
everyone to pay their
fair share at the top so we can make
permanent investments to rescue and
rebuild america
it's the right thing for our economy
it's the fair thing
it's the decent thing to do
we not only have an economic imperative
to act now
i believe we have a moral obligation
in this pandemic in america we cannot
let people go hungry
we cannot let people get evicted we
cannot watch nurses educators and others
lose their jobs we so badly need them
we must act now and act decisively
my fellow americans the decisions we
make in the next few weeks and months
are going to determine whether we thrive
in a way that benefits
all americans or that we stay stuck in a
place
where those at the top do great all
economic growth for most everyone else
is just a spectator sport and where
american prospects
dim not brighten these investments will
determine
whether we reassert american leadership
and out-compete our competitors in a
global economy
we're better equipped to do this in any
nation in the world
or that we watch them catch up and pass
us by
together i know which path
we'll choose that includes all americans
so we can own the 21st century
but even with all these ball steps it's
going to
take time to get where we need to be
there will be stumbles
but i will always be honest with you
about both the progress we're making and
what setbacks we meet and there will
and here's the deal the more people we
vaccinate
the faster we do it the sooner we can
save lives
and put this pandemic behind us and get
back to our lives and our loved ones
and the sooner we can rescue and rebuild
the american economy
the biggest and most profitable engine
in the world
i know it's been nearly a year
that tested us beyond measure
for all of you have lost someone my
heart goes out to you i know that
feeling looking at an empty chair across
the table
all of you fall on hard times
i know you can never get back what you
lost
but as your president i know that
every day matters and every person
matters
from the very first to the nearly 400
000 lost american souls and counting
to the millions of you just looking for
a fighting chance in this economy
i promise you we will not forget you we
understand what you're going through we
will
never ever give up and we will
come back we'll come back together
we didn't get into all this overnight we
won't get out of it overnight
and we can't do it as a separated and
divided nation
the only way we can do it is to come
together to come together
as fellow americans as neighbors
as the united states of america
and when we do there's nothing beyond
our capacity i've said this many times
when america acts as one there's never
been a single thing we've been unable to
do no matter how consequential
the issue has been out of all the peril
of this moment
i want you to know by giving a word i
see the promise
the promise as well we've seen clearly
what we face now
i remain so optimistic about america
as optimistic as i've ever been we have
everything we need
but the will must be demonstrated
so come wednesday we begin a new chapter
the vice president-elect and i will do
our best to meet all the expectations
you have for the country
and the expectations we have for it i'm
confident
i am truly confident together
together we can get this done
and come out better off than when we
went into this crisis
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops
have you heard from the parliamentarian
about bifurcation sir
will bifurcation work with this agenda